(baaing sheep)
- They're all calling you dad.
(classical guitar and keyboard)
- Gentlemen, would you like to start
with some onion rings as an appetizer.
Or maybe our bacon sampler,
which is five pieces of bacon
from all over the United States.
- Yes please, two bacon samplers, please.
- Two bacon samplers?
(classical guitar and keyboard with beats)
- '94 Dickerson.
- Ya.
- You know anything about.
- Ya, they're great, they're a
little bit on the green side.
- Which is fine.
- It's a cool vintage.
- Ya, I remember.
- But it's still Joel
Peterson that made it.
It's great stuff.
- Do you think we need to decant it?
- You can.
- Or do you think pop and pour's better.
- Um, we taste every bottle,
so I initially make a decision
and then we can consult.
- Okay cool.
- So let's grab it, I'll pop
it, and we'll talk about it.
- Thank you so much.
- I mean, there's so much old wine
that I'm just like, like this
'94 Ravenswood Zin Dickerson
was like, a wine a remember
selling when I was a kid.
You know, I was like,
this is gonna be really good wine one day.
Let's find out if I was right.
Hey guys, so these
couple vlogs are gonna be
a little bit different,
a little more vague,
because we're working
on a very secret project
that I'm super excited about.
I mean, look at Trouty's face,
look how secret this is.
But as you can imagine, if
you've seen some of the photos
on Instagram, put that up,
I think it's gonna be a very big deal,
I think you're gonna be
super excited about it.
I can't wait to announce it to all of you,
and so these two episodes I think
are going to really stand out
as a little different
side of me and my life,
and the world I play in.
And I think we're challenging ourselves
to show a little bit more of that.
We're so focused on giving value,
and it's really about
a motivational mindset
or a tactic, or giving you an
insight in to what I'm doing.
I've been seeing a lot more
of you tweeting things like,
you know, watch what
Gary's doing, whether it's
a Monday to Monday playlist or things.
Don't be scared Clay, get in here.
You can fix the meat while I'm ranting.
I'm almost done,
- Ya, I'm just.
- You do meat, I'll do this.
And so, that's what these
two episodes are about,
and I hope you enjoy them,
and I think value in the
vlog can come in the form
that 99% of the vlogs on YouTube have,
which is just entertainment,
and escapism, lightweight
just getting to know people,
and hopefully DRock and Bobby Babin
can do a good job editing these episodes,
and show you a little bit of those angles
that I don't think,
I think we agree we don't show enough of.
I'm way more funny than
you guys post edit me.
- [DRock] Well, you have more time now.
- Be funny right?
You know what, that's an
interesting insight, DRock.
Colin, write an article.
Monday morning, a lot of you checked out,
and enjoying President's Day, not me,
I'm up to some secrets, shhh.
(laughing)
- [Clay] They give them to you
as a season ticket holder.
So, what can I do, I don't
have small kids anymore,
nobody wanted them.
You hate the Warriors?
- I just like the Knicks.
(laughing)
How much money.
- Who said you L L C?
- I'm just a very big investor.
I always play for the long haul,
so early on, most of my
companies make no money.
And in one meeting, I was like,
look you don't understand,
we're making goose egg, nothing, zero.
- I lost.
- It was a very formal meeting with like,
billion dollar executives in ties,
I'm like fuckin' goose egg.
I was into it by summer I was like,
that wasn't too bad.
It feels so weird to have a lot of time,
I was antsy in the meeting.
- You're gonna have so
much fun with that story,
about explaining, like in
three minutes you explain,
or two minutes, explaining how fucked up
the wine business is,
you know how many people
don't understand that.
- When that clip plays in 40 years.
When this whole cycle goes down,
I'll enjoy that so much.
- Ya, that'd be cool.
So many people don't understand
what you were saying.
- I know.
- The rule, some bullshit
law from prohibition in 1930
has caused a dysfunctional
liquor and alcohol business
in this country.
- What time's our meeting?
- Well 3:30, so we're
supposed to be there now.
- So let's get there.
How far away are we?
- 10 minutes, eight minutes.
- Ya, no coffee.
If there's an archery
store, we'll stop by,
other than that.
(laughing)
- I love archery.
- He didn't see it, he didn't see it.
How good was that?
- I didn't know Gary was into archery.
- That was amazing.
- Last time he was here I
don't think he had a beer.
- Oh, I probably did, what's up?
- How are you, man.
John, good to see you again.
- You too.
- Hey man, Gary.
- Gary, Adam.
- How are you, Adam.
- Nathan.
- Or Nate, whatever you wanna call me.
- Nice to meet you.
- Daven.
- What's the name?
- Thanks for seeing us.
- This is Duke,
- Hey, Duke.
How are ya buddy?
- They're running a business here, John.
(laughing)
That's back to my thesis,
which is we're talking about Merlot.
We're talking about the
right bank of Bordeaux.
This is historic, this
is high quality wine.
One fuckin' movie.
In?
- [Male Off-Screen] Ya.
- Two.
- [Male Off-Screen] Year and a half.
- Just two really, right?
What up?
Ya, two.
That's when he came in?
- [Male Off-Screen] That
was the first one I did.
- [Gary] That's good man, that's early.
- The Rock just texted me.
(laughing)
- [Male Off-Screen] Are we
getting coffee around here guys?
- Guys, we'll get coffee when Avi says
we're gonna get coffee.
- [Male Off-sScreen] I'm in, I'm buyin'.
- When Avi has a Burger King on his side.
(laughing)
- Is he a Burger King guy?
- No, there's one right there.
I often reference what's in front of us.
- Archery and Burger King.
- Guys Bennett Realtors was the reason.
- Trouty's goin' deep.
- Trouty's diggin'.
Now we're seein'.
Here we go, want coffee,
but I want it from something
that's on our side, that doesn't veer off.
I don't like the U-turn.
And if we don't have anything,
we don't have anything.
If he dies, he dies.
Starbucks!
There it is.
- Yay.
- On our line.
- What.
- We gotta make a right, and then.
- No, it's a huge shopping center.
I feel like Avi missed
it, let's keep going.
Look I think the biggest thing,
first of all, I'm glad we
were able to make this happen.
I'm glad you texted me Victor.
And it's good to see
you, brother, I miss you.
Ah, class, listen, the opportunity,
you know, the biggest strength
and the biggest weakness is
the same thing for you guys,
which is, all of this is so
native and normal to you,
old guys like Victor and I, we realize
how fucking crazy this opportunity is.
The fact that it doesn't cost anything
to get out there, just
time and having talent
in a certain genre.
So the biggest thing I can tell you is,
please don't underestimate
how special this time is.
The internet is now at scale,
but it's still early, and
eventually it's gonna get
harder and harder and harder,
once everybody understands
this truth.
And so, what I'm doing is I'm going hard.
It's Instagram, it's
YouTube, it's Podcasting.
I'm just going all-in,
because I realize this is a moment in time
in the same way that Google AdWords
were a moment in time for
my dad's liquor store,
and how I grew that business.
So, I would say my biggest thing is,
hey, please take advantage of this.
Like the days of building
a million followers
on Instagram organic are going to go away,
and it's going to get harder.
And the fact that a lot of
this comes natural to you,
you know, obviously
you're taking this class,
you're thinking about your world,
but if you gotta passion
around a subject matter,
and you think you have something to say,
go hard, don't worry about
what other people think.
(music playing on cellphone)
That's how, a little patience.
- What'd I walk in to?
- Nothing, just, we were in town,
and we had the night, and
just emailed some people
we are fond of, and here we are.
Those people couldn't make it, so.
(laughing)
- [Male Off-Screen] Second string.
- We panicked and just sent a bulk email,
you guys replied.
Like, I wouldn't even
call them comparable,
so I just think it's the
way we take a lot of things
from Hollywood, and other
things of that nature.
But the advances, we've made.
- Are you saying the moon-landing
was Hollywood derived.
- No no no, not that.
Though it's amazing how
many people believe it.
I had this one guy tweeting me everyday.
That half bottle of Maiden, Trouty,
you sure you're willing to let that go?
Might wanna just pound it,
before we go to sleep.
I threw up all over my face.
Hey this is great.
(laughing)
Alright, you two, you two, you two.
- [Male Off-Screen] Do
you guys know each other
from previous lives?
- Ya.
- [Male Off-Screen] I mean,
all these guys know each other here?
- Ya, they found each other.
- You'll have some fun with this, right?
- Ya.
- John Deere, John Deere.
- I go John Deere?
- Fuckin' John Deere.
- 'Cause that's the, green, like Jeff.
Guys, you don't understand.
You'll love this, Clay,
my high school years,
my dad moved to a 28 acre farm
in Huntington County New Jersey, like,
this is like the city
compared to where I grew up
in my high school years.
- [Male Off-Screen] Really?
- Ya, so, you know, Jersey's funny,
like there's pockets of
Jersey that are super rural.
I grew up in Iowa, not, even
though it was in Jersey.
And even I live in Manhattan, like,
this is normal shit for me.
Our cow was like my pet.
So like, I'm being dead-fuckin' serious.
We're a far way away from me selling it
for 633 retail.
Clay why'd fuck me up.
Ah-ha, there it is.
Well, I'm only as good as.
I'm a Brooke 2013.
- That's his daughter.
- Me and Brooke, 2013.
I swear to God, look.
- Oh man.
- Ya, I'm in there.
- Not even.
- Oh, over six foot.
What's that.
- [Male Off-Screen] We need to adjourn.
- Guys, you see that renovation,
you see that renovation?
That's going to be a boot room.
You're gonna walk in there
and it's gonna be all boots.
Really?
- He's already got one.
I'm coming up Clay.
(laughing)
Clay, I'm coming up.
I wanna see the boot room.
Show me the boot room.
- [Clay] This is the partial boot room.
These are work boots.
- They really are, huh?
Why are they so expensive,
'cause this is like
crocodile or somethin'?
- Lucchese's.
- For boots?
- Ya, they're fuckin' nice too.
- You like wearing boots?
- I think I seen these
things for like three bucks
at garage sales, it's incredible.
- (laughing) These,
see these are all worn.
- You have any Jets' jerseys?
- Very good at it.
- Ya.
- I don't know, I have
no fear, so you know,
how people, oh if I can make this.
Fuck you, I'm pretty sure
I'm not going to make this,
drop here, I'm not gonna do this,
I'm not gonna make this placement,
so if I have no fear,
everything else is a bonus.
- I totally agree with you.
- And everybody goes in there
thinkin', I want I want,
I'm like, I don't really want this.
I have a different way of farming,
and a different way of thinking.
- Me too.
- I focus on the negatives.
- And I fix the negatives.
- Me too.
- You wanna manage the positives?
- No, I wanna fix the bottom line.
I wanna fix the issues.
- Same fuckin' thing.
That's all I do, right?
That's all I spend my time on.
Do you know I say I'm a firefighter?
When I go in to, when I write occupation,
when I come back in to America,
I put firefighter.
- I said that this morning.
My daughter walks in, she
goes, I need five minutes
of your time for you to
look at this newsletter.
I said, I'm puttin' out fuckin' fires,
it's what I do every fuckin' morning.
I don't worry about the good.
- Have no time to smell roses.
- Fuck it.
- I just didn't want her to bite anybody.
- She bites?
- Well, no, but I'm always worried
'cause she's so fuckin' protective.
- Oh, right, so I kiss on the cheek,
and she bites my face off.
- Nah, she hasn't but I'm
just, fuck, always worried.
- Hey, I think it's
gonna be sunny tomorrow,
what's the data?
It'd be a great SNL skit, Data Dan,
no matter what you say,
he just plugs in data
on the spot, and if you don't have it.
For the last 30 years, I think
the best thing we can do,
I mean I think we're having
a tactical discussion
in the short term, and I'm thrilled,
and I think I'm head-nodding
on a lot of this stuff.
But I don't want to deviate from the thing
that I think is the most powerful,
and I'd love to get people's thoughts,
which is, we need to ammo and flood
15 to 25 year olds in the
channels that they consume
with messages like (silence),
some sort of rallying cry,
that gives them the ammo,
because they're the new energy,
and they, I absolutely believe,
the drunk driving, smoking thing
that was brought up 15 minutes ago,
was the most important insight,
because it wasn't the establishment
or the people that were in it,
it was the people underneath
that changed the movement.
Our greatest ammo is
persuading and informing,
but I think selling to the un-sellable
is a wrong play, and I
think on both sides of this.
We are too numb and normalized,
and I think this seed of 18 year olds
and 16 year olds being
pissed off and having ammo,
just like them starting
the biggest companies
in the world, is exactly
where we should go,
with a punch of different messages,
and let them grab on to something, and go.
And I think that they could absolutely
affect the outcome.
(classical guitar and keyboard)
- It's really rad.
Got a use for this vine.
Bang.
- [Male Off-Screen] All
like the ca-ryn-yons gone
before people realize they like it,
and start replanting it again.
- [Gary] Same old thing.
- [Male Off-Screen] Ya, always.
(classical guitar and keyboard)
(classical guitar with keyboard and beats)